الناخبون من الاصول اللاتينيه الجائزه
الرابحه التي يتسابق عليها الجمهوريون
والديمقراطيون لا عجب في ذلك فهم الاسرع
عموما في امريكا وكسبهم يعني كسب المزيد
من مقاعد الكونجرس فالدستور ينص صراحه على
اعاده توزيع المقاعد كل عشر سنوات تبعا
للتعداد السكاني بحسب تقسيم هذه الدوائر
سيطره جمهوريون على 278 دائره بالكونغرس
بينما الديمقراطيون سيطروا فقط على 75
دائره رقم اقل بكثير من منافسهم عرف عن
الناخبين من الاصول اللاتينيه دعمهم
الدائم للديمقراطيه الا ان انتخابات 2020
كشفت التوجهات جديده اللاتينيه وتوجهت
اسهم بعضهم نحو المرشحين الجمهوريين اي
الرئيس ترامب رغم جدته للهجره وللمره
الاولى في تاريخ الولايات المتحده شارك
اكثر من 32 مليون لاتيني في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه اما في عام 2022 هناك مسرح جديد
لاختبار اتجاهات اللاتينيين في الانتخابات
النصفيه ستظهر ما اذا كانت توجهات عام
2020 مستمره ام لا عند الحديث عن الملفات
الخلافيه الانتخابات النصفيه هي الساحه
التي يعبر فيها اللاتينيون عن ارائهم
باداره بيض لملفات تمسهم كالهجره وحقوق
التصويت حيث تظهر استطلاع راي ان معظمه
اللاتينيه يفضلون الديمقراطيين اما
اقتصاديا هناك حوالي واحد 41% من الناخبين
اللاتينيين يتفقون مع الجمهوريين بشان
الملفات الاقتصاديه في مقابل ثلاثه
واربعين بالمئه للديمين فيديو
كرستين الرب
[موسيقى]